[Music]
time now for final exam what we
determined through rigorous testing
which of our employees are paying
attention to the work they do
this week's defending champion is Fox
News correspondent Griff Jenkins still
injured but still razor sharp his
challenger fox business correspondent
Kiska christina parts necklace
welcome to Fox in to the show we're
really glad to have excited thank you
okay you know who you're up against I
know
Christina welcome by the way she is
brilliant she speaks like five languages
I'm doomed this is ready to go he
understands it every time okay I'm sure
you know the rules because I don't even
glued to this but in case you need a
refresher here's where they are I ask
the questions hands on buzzers the first
person to buzzing gets to answer you
must wait until I finish asking the
question in order to buzz in each
correct answer is worth a single point
if you get a question wrong a point is
detracted from your total best of five
wins are you ready yeah are you ready
ready that's good
question one the Wall Street Journal
reports this week that Amazon the
company may now terminate your account
if you do what too often
holy smokes he's on fire too many
refunds you return to any items send
them back really hmm
roll tape some Amazon customers saying
they were banned from the site for
making too many returns whoa
people in that cab users who had their
accounts story for Fox Business News so
at the decisiveness that slap was
impressed strong all right question two
there was a hairy situation this week at
San Antonio International Airport a wild
animal got loose and ran around that
facility what kind of animal wasn't
Grif Jenkins a let me think I have to
get my ape species
it was a baboon a baboon
well that's specific I think you say
lemur wasn't a bad moving roll tape
there was just one monkey wandering
around the airport cargo hold the rhesus
macaque named Dawkins was confined to an
area away from passengers it took dozens
of animal workers about an hour to
capture the elusive guy okay so this is
look I don't have a whole panel of
judges and do they just ding you they
tamed me all right sorry
come on arm come on this is tough this
is tough okay that's unbelievable and
and our judges just said that due to
technical difficulties your total is not
reflected on screen but it's one to
negative one okay I have a lot of weigh
together this could be it score boats
doing crazy now you've got three but
look we're the final call here yeah
question three one of the most talked
about moments that the Royal Wedding was
a performance by the kingdom choir they
sing a gospel version of which 1960s
classic song I watched it stand by me
stand by me Benny King is that correct
[Music]
I think it's the first time they've ever
had
stand by me choir in that I didn't see
the wedding but I like that that was
really nice ok so it's 0 to 1 you're
coming back this one multiple choice New
York City Mayor Bill de Blasio is
backing a proposed bill this week that
would ban which plastic product from All
City restaurants is at a bottles be
utensils see straws Grif Jenkins I'm
guessing here straws straws just the
Blasio move is it straws
advocates say too many straws end up in
landfills and the oceans one of the
proposed bill restaurants and fast food
chains would be barred from giving
straws out you know I don't know how we
found ourselves in the final round in
sudden death with no hide 1 to 1 right
it's sort of the laid-back politeness
the physical incapacitation final
question ok ready there we go during a
Yale commencement speech on Sunday
Hillary Clinton the former Secretary of
State tried her hand at prop comedy by
putting on what kind of hat Griff
Jenkins a Russian had a Russian hat a
Russian it's kind of warm for that isn't
it let's see does the tape backup Grif
Jenkins a Russian hat it would have been
a great joke
love the way that Hillary is yeah just
learn one of the most valuable lessons
about working here at Fox Christina and
I know you're gonna be here a long time
in prosper now that you know it okay
never could be with grip I would never
reach the end she'll be reporting from
Washington here oh I love free well
welcome thank you great today great to
meet you Griff here's the Eric wimple
mug row thank you you have many do you
want to give this once he's got many
yeah he's got a whole collection he's
going me and the sling we're collecting
them all it's unbelievable I hope you'll
come back yes that's it for this week
follow the news each and every week and
see if you can beat our experts here at
Fox we are back next Thursday Memorial
Day will be airing by the way the
ultimate final exam is going to feature
the best moments from the past year of
this segment and it's